very good
[Music]
and if they have all
I'm fine
if the volume is turned up
well
perfect just as it has been programmed
my quiet neighborhood quite calm
I have gone out very little and they still make me go out
too much I still have not incorporated
too much they
bought they are going to buy a little
plus work has gone a bit like this I came
here on vacation because I'm already in
Canada and I came to see my parents
and I no longer remember what happens because of the issue
of visas I had to with a few months and I came
here and there the next  visa and
fair actor alarm status
hello hello
good afternoon
good
in Spain now what time is it
now
the meeting I was in I was at
dawn well well
in Spain dinner at eleven past
midnight well possibly not I
remember that when
I didn't  I know we have to go with my wife
we ​​went to the restaurant at nine
thirty
and there was no one who came. Do you want
the gentleman doing here we are going
ten and a half days
we are all patricio hello hello greetings
good  nas
marquis
what i am here hello everyone
well it's a pleasure to have you here like me
well firstly I'm anna I work
online in the marketing department
so it's a pleasure for me to be able to
do this webinar for everyone
good for everyone in my country and the  other countries
that speak Spanish it
is a pleasure Francisco Patricio Antonio does not know so much
that they are users of the
link they do not know how to explain a little their
experience within the link and how they
use it and how well they
benefit from their learning and of
course we have steve  that for me
it is always a pleasure to have him and learn
from him because his advice is always
very good and above all the motivation
that he gives that if he can, we can all
do it and I think that this is a great message
and that it motivates, which is fundamental for me
I don't know how you want a little bit if
you want to start I also want to
explain a bit no longer as I think
you can explain this a bit how
you use the link but I'm going to focus a bit  A bit
more as a Spaniard who always had
problems with English, as the link has
helped, it has helped me to get
re-enlisted a bit and not have that fear
of going back to study English,
so I wanted to explain it a bit
like this, so if you want I can
explain and start  First with the
story or whatever you
want. I also want it to be better if you start and
well, and then I can give some
comments, okay, well, I imagine that
like me there are many, I don't know if the rest
of the countries, but in Spain, well, I
think I'm a  reflection of a group of
people who started to study English when they were
very young but there is always a
frustration not because it has been very
focused on grammar if we had a
good one a good one more traumatic but
then when watching a movie
or when traveling  or at the time it is with two
salts and you say wow yes I have been
studying English for eight years but I don't know how to defend myself no I do
n't know I don't know how to communicate
so well not many like me for
example imagine saying  You want to go
abroad and you say, well, I'm going
abroad for three months to see if that's how
I'm going to improve my English, well, they're
worth it, you're going, you're going to spend a lot of money and you
're going to another country, and well, if you're going to
class, but a little  It's the same if
you can communicate with people again
but, well, I think you fall back
into the same thing a bit, so well, I
went to Canada, there are also good reasons to
learn to
improve my English, but I was
lucky, not among them.  It's good to
know the link to work in the
marketing department and thinking
that I, well, languages ​​are
not my thing because then why am I worthless
because I've been here for many years and mine
don't know English
with links that he gave me and for me what
contributes to the link is that when you already have
a grammar base that we already have and
we are already very tired of those
grammar exercises we are tired
of books that have no interest oysters well
this is a platform that tells you
or  You can study with the content that
you like, okay, I don't like English very much,
but if I usually watch
makeup videos on YouTube, it's like this because
I don't use this content in a link because
in this way, well, I'm watching
content that I like  and at the same time he
took advantage of the time and I am
learning English so for me it was one of
the great benefits of the link not only
at the youth level but at the marketing level, for
example, because for me it is
that I needed a vocabulary
within marketing so to be able to
any article, well,
any content that seemed interesting to me to be
able to import the link and the
link was my readers, it became
my site where I could read, of course, it allowed
me to evolve more in my
vocabulary and in the way of delving
into English and well, it is a  little my history
and I think that this point
has helped me the link for what I say
because I think that for me for the
Spanish it is not that we have ones that we do not
have  a base in English if
we have it and we have a good grammar
but we lack that fluency that listening
so I think the link helps that
and also well doing it with a
content that maybe you like then
the motivation is greater so this is
a  little my contribution from me we have
from my perspective
steve what do you think
I don't know what we are going to do because well
all of us have participated
[Music]
the meetings lately we cannot
repeat the same thing because now
we have a Spanish speaking Spanish
Spanish speaking public I  I don't know what
you think
we are going to show a bit to share the
screen or we are going to talk more
generally about our experiences
with language learning the
experience with link maybe it would be better to
start with this and according to that need
we can show some things on the
screen but  many people who didn't
didn't know well because we have
we have one I think we all
agree that he learned  Language change
depends on a lot of people, well, there's a lot of listening,
there's a lot of reading, it
's a little different from what people
believe in. It should be the role of a school,
not to teach, to explain, and for us it's
more a matter of getting used to a
language, but I think we can
Explain a bit about the link method in
the beginning and a bit about how everyone
uses the system, but better me in
Giovanna's account and then Francisco Antonio and Platita, well, Patricio Antonio,
we can follow this in this order, yes, yes, you
want.
again in
English we talked a little about the basic topic
we agree on the fundamentals in
my experience it was already a long time
learning language much more than anna
of course
other things and I discovered a method
let's say based on based on input
based on comprehension  a little on my
own for a long time I've been
interested in languages ​​learning English and
French
once an interesting thing is that
really in the school  school, I was
interested in languages
because my father knew some French and he
actually had a lot of it and he had
books I wanted to understand them and so
I went to French class and I liked it
but I learned very little and I remember that
I was very curious I remember that there was  a
song for eurovision a long
time ago the spanish song but it
had the name in french and title in
french called bollywood 11 adequá
do you want to dance with me
and at school they asked do you understand it
and I discovered that I did not understand that he was
dedicated to knowing what it is like  about
super basic things after they took them
to children's school for two years
I didn't even understand that but I discovered an
absolute disaster and I left it and when
I wanted to go back to that some time later, well,
a company buying candles to
read novels with a lot of effort with a
dictionary  buy a shortwave radio
and then I really sew using
a method with lynn's only without
internet and means for a lot  much
heavier and really I already told it the
other time but for a moment I
thought with a small application for
Latin
with some work by Caesar by Julius Caesar
and you could click on each word to
understand it so I thought oh this
is wonderful  I wish there was something
similar but for any language and
that's nice nice discovered a
lot that for me it's a link basically they
are a button well you say the subject of
reading that those novels
that I had such a hard time reading can be made
much easier much faster  and
indeed it is a bit the key the
key is that I did not tell it the other time
I do not want to repeat myself too much but above
all the link learned Russian to start
with Japanese but above all Russian
and I started little by little but in the end what
I liked the most  allows to learn was reading
novels that allows you to read novels
at a level that is not so tremendously
advanced
really enjoys and is the only one
really for people who can
dedicate
limited  as for me the only way to
get to a high level of languages ​​is to
really face
complicated material native
auditory really make them enjoy
read more understand more etc etc etc
the great myth and basically that's it the
other time in the other meeting he explained a
little details  we can go back in if
you want but basically yes
about how he used the yen that I have
languages ​​now
I want to make a comment.
I agree that we have to
focus on comprehension
and I said that after so many years of
French at school I didn't
even know the word of honor which is something
very basic
but to me I thought that a young man would be good
for learning languages
worley because  there are very basic things
that you are going to forget or not be able to
use but this is not
important because you can learn the
word beck after n  or there is
no order and neither are difficult things
difficult words you can learn very
early so
why are there people that I forget something very
very basic but this does not matter we are going to
forget very basic things and
surely you are going to learn very difficult things
very quickly very early  there is no order
and there is no order
our memory remembers a very
good example that appeared in a link forum
some time ago from another
very active link user learning Russian and the name
that greetings to him from here and I remember
that one  Once he wrote he said he always
forgot the word open hugged and that
as an education but remember for rosé
what it means mermaid that in a certain
sense very absurd but you really
learn if there is indeed
no order it is something you will surely
find secondary interests and sometimes a
saying of  a very mysterious way the
brain works like this no matter
what you think let's go with antonio
you are the boss anna is the driver
of pardons that too  they are watching
the questions on youtube if there were any
questions that's good but if antonio
can you explain your
experience to us a bit at the link and if you explain to us if
well well only all of us in this video have
known each other for a while too and
I using this method well then some
How many years old
and well, although Patricio
surely hasn't had the experience of
Francisco and Steve due to age and
well, we've been using this
platform for a few years now,
my personal experience is that like everything else,
you start to learn English
at school.  In primary school it's like
they say in Spanish and I also
went to an English academy after school. It
's supposed that going to an academy going
to school you should have a
considerably high level and well, when I was 16
years old or so, I already had a level
quite high but I do not relate it
simply to that but also to the
interest that English culture produced in me,
the language, etc. I
relate it more to  interesting things that I
did outside of class
I put on the interesting content and the truth is
that I enjoyed it
and if I then compared my level to the level
of the rest of the classmates, it had
nothing to do with it because they were
simply interested in other things, which
is also perfectly  respectable so
well the link is a bit this is to be able to
learn from content that you like whether it
is from videos movies series whatever
news and that is how I have been
doing it this time now
I am currently improving my German I am dedicated
to exporting and I have  I have to talk
every day with customers from
different European countries so
well one of the new markets is
Germany and I'm trying to improve it if
you want I'll share the screen with you a bit
and we'll see where they are if I don't have a
thousand things known
screen
and well how  You see, German is a
language that is trying to improve and if
we go to lessons
and
you will see the type of content that I
use, no.  We are going to see in my lessons
Beijing quick boards well I am
trying to go from an intermediate level he
has advanced in German and as you can see here I
use a lot of news news with audio
this for example in German does not have the
deutsche welle and it is quite useful and if
not well  I care about any type of
news that interests me current news that I
can really use in a
conversation with one of the clients
things that interest me then good
content like this there is a lot on the
internet there is also content in
links that can be used from the
beginning but  That's the idea, then another
of the positive things I see about Link
after so long is the creation
of the community.
I think we
always need external motivation
to learn a language,
for example, the videos that Steve has been
making for so many years, because I
personally love  have been motivated to
learn these languages
and therefore it
is something that you would not have in other types of
applications, for example, for  To learn
languages, then all this type of, for
example, keep learning the strict language active for 90 days,
and Steve, well,
all that type of thing helps you
spend every day every
day now only what each
one has that I see as quite interesting and
Well, an Antonio question that I already
imagine we know what it is but for
them to understand what differences you see
for example because we know that
you can read that news and that content is
worth a web page but what is
the benefit of caring about the link
because  you see that benefit link
I think that the more you use it the more you
need it link is your database of
languages
that is to say to me if tomorrow the link
of the world will close for example because studying
the underlined words that are more
than 8000 or do you know where they come from  I find them, that
is, it would be very complicated, so it
is simply being able to read the content
you want and then being able to review all
those words that will
appear  later in other texts and if they
appear
then that is the way I
use links and I think the
fact of having an increasingly
larger community is good, I think it helps
me a lot to answer this question
sometimes it seems to me  Well, it's a
habit, it's not an addiction, it's a specific drug,
a way of learning
languages ​​that's very effective, but it's also
that. I feel good when I'm
working with the link because then
I think it's good when someone starts
not knowing very well.  well how to use
there are certain difficulties to enter
enter the link but once you
are comfortable with the link it is the
only one it is the only legal one for a place to
learn languages
yes yes I think that if there really are
many applications we all know about
bullying or etc.  and the truth is
that after two days people have already
eliminated them because it is boring repetitive content,
no, it is nothing
, it motivates us to continue learning
and highlighting  a bit of benefit because
a person can but because I'm going to
have to use the link been the news
I can I can read it on the website it's
a bit that's not to follow the tracking
of all your evolution of your words to
have it all in one  site to have a leader
who is also easy to read
so there are few benefits
provided by the link why it has what
you say there you open a bookstore this is your
bookstore you have your treasure there and what
it means to keep is a bit that the
benefit I think that the great with the
great question seems to me because what in
fact Antonio is that methods to
start in one language and many in many
and we may like one more than another
speaks of your language and that he likes it a lot
in lingua and  no, but in any case it is useful
to start, that is to say, to find
the first level, not at the level, it is not very
difficult to enter because I said before,
schools learn basic basic English,
but the passage of a level goes from
a very basic level to a higher level.  the stop
that kind of this time talks about the check
the hockey stick as you start
faster then be very slow in the
really difficult part that part in my
personal experience required me other
languages ​​when there was no income more
reading novels trying to understand the
radio will hit etc. it is from the system and it
is very difficult it is very hard if some
languages ​​are
much more complicated it makes it easier for me that
allows you to access a level to a material
I would say
at a level higher than yours it turned out a
certain level allows you to pass a
material higher than  your level because
because basically it does it like you don't
read and they mark the words
and even the phrases that I am now
with Japanese for example there are many
words that I don't understand even if I understand
the words I don't understand the sentence that
happens very often okay allow
that márquez the words that marc is the
phrase that márquez
is a set the expression for example
and stores it as well said by antonio
but it also explains understands it
so it allows you to understand
quite complicated things and it is the way to
really pass a high level which is
a long process and whoever is
enjoying the means possible because it is
a marathon
very well if in the end it is yes a bit go
working nothing
and what you talk about what you talk about at the end
as the child you can have all the
content at the end well you can also
progress
at the
patrician level if you want to pass your now
explain a little experience in
link this good to me always  They have
liked languages
but I had never been able to learn with
methods that I like because, for
example, when I was younger, my
brothers did not ask him to do homework
in Portuguese Rosetta Stone
or whatever and I
often did their homework because I wanted to because
I liked it but it kind of felt like I
was staying in words and I couldn't connect
anymore, that is, I could say cake, I could
say gas station, but I couldn't reach
more.  I know about that this then later well
obviously with the school with the school
that I stopped liking languages ​​after
a while because they began to
qualify them
as if it were a thing to show them
how it looks I want to show that I know although
in reality the objective is not to show  It's
is learning
so it provides French for two out of three
years and I had to take exams
this summer but after that I started to
learn well and then I discovered the link
and the process sped up a lot because
you can basically learn whenever
you want you don't have to depend on
Whether it's the class or if you have
classes and you're in quarantine and you
can't learn anything
, you avoid all these types of things by having a good
system that you can apply from home
and best of all, things if
you want to see a  content that is more
difficult than what your level allows you
at a certain moment is simply
imported by salling and you can end
up being able to see things more difficult  It is or you know
very difficult news that maybe you don't
understand it matters salling and it no
longer becomes easier for us to understand it and this
is how you are improving quickly
very well in
the end well we all share a little
idea about about link how it helps us
to  continue to grow in the language
I don't know if I would also like to and now I'm going
to be a bit by the
marketing department because I already have here I also
want to take advantage of that I don't know if this is
something missing the link if you think it's
not an idea say well no  I know it
is always good to listen to the voices of the
users, not that in the end I am what you
use and that you can tell us the
truth that users always
tell us things but so I would like
you to not know that you contribute your
grain of sand in this  sense
I'm not Francisco if you want to start
I remember I can start yes well
obviously you can always do more
and more obviously one thing and
complicated by that difficult but like
The idea is already starting to launch ideas, not the idea
of ​​trying to get content, since it works that way for
him, too, with a kind
of let's say from some times to
proposals in the forum, a kind of
bookstore where perhaps he also sells
books because the problem is that later
we will find  some languages ​​are very
difficult and they are usually protected
for reading the famous since rn so
you can't that they are ideas within two
words but the idea of ​​getting
content that you can actually buy
that content directly the day you
import it directly can be very
useful for  some languages ​​where it is very
difficult, for example, Indonesian,
where that is very complicated,
Google play is studying a lot because of
that, because it is very
easy, that would have very powerful
novels and other books without protection,
but
a resource is very difficult for me, I already do a little  echo of those of us
who studied Japanese I started I learned the
Japanese grammar output but not much
vocabulary and emp  It has become stronger now and
the rest of us who learn Japanese and
again difficult to understand but there is the
question that of course seeing Japan is the
most complicated and frequently where
the word begins where each other as
it becomes very useful what the
link has  It automatically allows for each
kanji each Japanese character to put its
pronunciation
but it doesn't always work well
obviously because it's very complicated
so in this kind of things that kind of
good and very suggestions lori amazing
people
perfect if I don't understand well he
repeated I said we should sell sell
books intrigued with  the system but it
is something that we think we want to do
but we have tried to connect with
publishing houses but they do not
answer or they think that we
do not have perhaps that we do not have
enough as a market no but we are going to
continue in that sense this is  for me it
is worth it to buy a
Libyan air book with the digital book twenty
euros q  That this for me in any language
is a month of work a
month of work so if we can
sell and hope that each member of the
link will look for himself in Polish in
what language that is not known very
well what will  search and find things
audio books and the context that you can
that he can import the link is a bit
much for each member if we
can offer this they offer this to
our members of course it would be
very good and so we are thinking about
how to do it in  sell books audio
book with texts integrate it with the
link maybe the audio cannot be
integrated because it costs a lot of work
to share in chapters no but
at least check the book integrate it
with a link that you can search in our in
our library library things that you
they like it already integrated but at a
good level level better good audio
interesting and good content it is sure that it is
something that we are going to do but disney for
step by step let's go  to bring this one closer to
this goal I didn't have to say that
I also wanted to say to Patricio that he
said that well in link you can work
with more difficult things
because there are all the functions that help you
well to this challenge not more
difficult things possibly more interesting
but  if you want to
try to read it in a normal book it is
too difficult but with lync
good things the content like 20 25 percent
of words that you don't know already you can
use them and that is a great advantage for
the link but there is also another side
for  example with reference to the problem
with the Franciscan Japanese when
we started now I always start with
the ministries mini stories so
there are simple things and that allows you to
start with the language because
language learning is a matter of
getting used to the language that the brain
is  one is a machine of patterns,
patterns, not that it will look for patterns
of relationships,
even if you don't
know, you know the rules.  those of grammar the
brain with its office while it hides a
lot on input it will look for
relationships and patterns and but they must and
when you have to work on the
simple things to be able to realize to
figure out those patterns and then
work on more difficult things where it is
more  It is difficult to realize those
formulas of those patterns and I think that
the link
is very useful to me is that
possibility of working with
simple things in Arabic now and
also more difficult things,
well then, and I think it is a good
strategy.  not always sticking to
simple things but not even if
difficult things are really
difficult it's a bit frustrating and you're
always looking for words and you know the
words but you don't understand them very well in
the full sense no so this
variation between simple things and
difficult things is very important  for
language learning it is one thing that
is available in the link in
a very very easy way and I think that  This is one
of the great advantages of the
link
Yes, Antonio, if you want, well, if you want to
talk to us about a proposal for possible
improvements, you will get, I share a little of
what Francisco has said,
basically, for example, I am now
also learning Chinese, which I
just have here with a  símil
is a very well-known publishing house in the
polyglot world, so be it 1,018 self I
think it is not a good proposal to be
able to buy the book directly the
link that I do every day because
I have to type character by character in the
link the lessons of assimilate and  bonus is
a little more work but it
can also be done if you could buy these
books directly there perfect at
least the best known did not assimilate
teacher self
but well I wanted to comment that
last week one of the participants
where last Monday recommended that  If
you want to pass something to the link and you don't want
to transcribe it, you can scan it
with google translate and once
You can copy it for the Canelas and send it to you
because it can be tested Watson game by
mail and then it doesn't matter anymore instead of
transcribing each thing three rules the
canes with the google translate application
that may be an option for certain
languages ​​but not others  I know if I
put this in google translate it won't read it's
who knows because of age maybe yes
the program of programs that make
character recognition more
complicated more complicated in any case
buying is interesting and not just a
textbook like that very directly
schools are still here but also an
asset material very interesting novels
languages ​​that are difficult I don't know a little
about them but it is difficult for example and
others like Nordic languages ​​it has a
very interesting literature but almost
all of it is protected
in many very interesting ways
if I  from the marketing department
I also tell us that it is one of the things
that we want to implement in the end
we know that our base  I also know to be able to
have water, it has good content, because it is
not, in the end, the bigger the
bookstore, the better the users for you to
go there and already have all the content
you are looking for, which is good at a level, because
we already know that there are always some
problems.  but hey, we're working on them and
I suppose we'll be working
anyway, Steve, I would also like to take the
opportunity to ask you what you wanted to
answer to this question of the simile
before tackling.
I've been
dealing with gmail for a long time and I know these
people because they often come to
polyglot conferences
but they say yes but it's difficult I'm going to see
value and finally no then but
we're going to continue it
's a matter of good we have to
present things better
inside  of our libraries so that,
for example, editions like this seem
better to me because now it is a little
lost among many  The contents are one thing
that we have in mind that we want to
do and if not, then a thousand, well, we already have
a quantum south relationship with the
things they should and Louis, which is the edition of the
titus of war collection. I forgot that but I'm
sure we're going to continue  to
try to do that and we have
contacts but many times they do not
answer because they consider that we are
too small no so it is
a question that the link becomes
bigger that we have slightly better libraries
so
that their contents do not come out and well  there are
many things but the principle is
good that we want to sell
it would also be one as revenue poli says
because if we sell things we can touch
like 10 or 15 percent no if it is certain
that it is something we want to do let's
see
yes now to finish honest  and that at a
level, for example, we are
working in a bookstore, as
Steve explained, the idea is also that of
not only having the content because
it has  We don't want a bookstore to be one of the
largest on the Internet, but for
users it is much easier to access it,
it is much more filtered. If I ask
interests, then this is our focus
now, not to facilitate the search for that
content so that the user who arrives can find
it.  You can find an easy
and accessible way at your level, your interests,
which is not what we are,
so a great library where you
can find a lot of content,
so well, in that line we know that
we are working so well, we see
that we are somewhat aligned and  that's
good because it's a bit what everyone is
looking for without dressing
steve here was the question for me with
english it happened to me that i want to focus on
the american accent and on the
levels above all i find the
english accent etc 1 c 2 well do you want
someone  can you explain how to use
netflix and youtube because there are a lot of
things there with the american accent
it's level i think it's level i want to sit  u and you
can import things from youtube netflix
day of the american don
speak with the accent not so much
understand them if you want good to
focus on the american accent you don't
have to speak you have to
listen to it because if you don't listen you can't be
good
at the question it is not very clear
me  I would give you advice for the
production part, yes, the
more it sounds, the better
netflix can be imported, they cannot be
imported from a link, videos from youtube,
videos from youtube, many Americans
choose a topic that interests them how they
liked with makeup, not how
I started  with skating or dancing
choose some from youtube and
import them try to find good ones
that have subtitles that is a way
to produce there is a youtube channel it
is more gap or english
where she is an american teacher and she
places a lot of emphasis on action sometimes very
detailed pronunciation of how to
pronounce the part I would
already recommend this channel
and I for example  For me, for the subject of the
accent, it's still basic but a little more
slang has gone well for me, for example, the chapters
of friends because they are like that, it's very day
to day, so it's gone a bit to the
most basic conversations, so
we don't have no  The
entire episodes are on YouTube because you have to
pay for them but you find small pieces of
the series so what they were doing
mattered to them a little bit about the American day-
to-day
between friends that helps you a
little to get that basic fluidity no no
I know what level you want but sometimes
we look a bit for that fluidity of these
has helped me a bit to accept that level.
I don't know if anyone else wants to contribute
on the matter of importing from a
web page or from YouTube Netflix,
maybe there are
teeth that don't  they know that you
can use the import extension
to easily import things from
youtube from netflix or from newspapers and
once you have this by extension it
seems like only machine well they can
look  Doing a danger on YouTube can
explain about it
and you will automatically see the text if
there is, if there is more,
although only for and to explain what
they do not know, because
we are assuming that many
users do when they know it, but it
cleans an extension.  The browser that
you have to download doesn't have it if it
's in the browser, well, you can go to
YouTube to select the video you
want to hear what we're talking about that
has the subtitles, the captions, you'll see
that the icon can be shared, the
icon is in your browser  click like this
automatically I opened the link from
the link and you will be able to see both the video, the
text and the audio so it is very
interesting because you can be
listening to the audio and the text me for
example one of the things that also
matters to me are the t ex  from different
people because there are many many good
conferences of many types of
economics where
the tekis come from so I think it is also
for English I also  they work very
well
the comment says yes but I wanted
more content in
in the library the
american accent let's see let's
see let's see let's see from time to time it's a
matter of the tags that we have
what
from time to time I'm sure  that every
time it is a North American accent or
an English accent that there is a time for
that day it is easier to look for things in a
certain accent to someone who was
studying Spanish is that they want to
learn the Mexican accent that we have
for all the contents that are
contained  that they are Mexicans that there is the
tape and you can search for Mexican and we are going to
see Mexico or Portugal Brazil or
whatever and in a few years you already had it and I think I
remember that it did come out we have but
not always the people who
download content not always  they put the
tag no with the accent it is a job that
we are going to do now so that
our library is better not than if it
is mexican it is mexican if it is spain or
portugal or scotland au  stralia that there is a
tag and you can look for the attention you
want north america or whatever
we have that the earth
is watching me see on youtube if
we have any questions but
[Music]
no people well well really
questions no yes they tell
us thanks  for helping that sometimes for
being there
[Music]
but like this
we don't see any questions I don't know if
steve to end this webinar or seal a
bit I would like
the Hispanic community to tell us your
advice that you know works and that
I  I know it's also good to listen to them again
because that also helps a
little to motivate us again and I think
it's very interesting because our
members see other
members how they use what they think
so we've done I don't know five or
six times in  English now we want to
do it not in other languages ​​we have done it
in Russian and now in Spanish it's later I
don't care what's
good thank you all game by
game next time
okay
Well, thank you very much for your
participation and I suppose we'll
see if we want to share ideas
as well as doing some more in Spanish,
maybe more specific, but not the same, we can
share more specific things about
YouTube or about content or about a
language that I think will also
help this  It is a bit more generic, I was
also looking at it to open everything up a bit,
but I think that the following ones
can go on doing more specific things,
a question to whether I
understand, you know, and if you can remember
the words, it is not always this
question that we have to address.  force or
work or try to learn every
word in the content or we have to
go on and look for other content and
all the words and structures and
phrases you need you will find
again so when you want to
progress to new content content
please
because all  the necessary words you are
going to find him again is a
question when already a with  I had
determined that he is already bored it is very
important because because of the brain to
look for new things because when the brain
is done it is because it is bored
it was not learning so at a
certain point if the repetition is very
good very good but you also have to
look for new things and  the repetition
will
appear naturally because in each it is
the same language no then it will
appear in other contents yes I understand
the question the question
antonio you wanted to add something
good you have seen a question on youtube to
see if you wanted to answer it is
about a teacher  who asks how you can
use link as a support for your
students in traditional classes
I can appear in the marketing part
then it is a tip if you want you too from the
part more about how link can help me
from the marketing part I can say that
we have a platform
specific for schools where those of
each school or teacher have their classes
by levels or for whatever they want to do.  r
language and from there you can access all
the tracking that we see individually, such as
teachers, they can access and see the
monitoring of the students, that is,
we also have what we speak, a
platform for schools and we already have
schools with which they work and find it
very interesting.  In a way, not in some
way to introduce something much more digital to the classrooms,
outside of texts,
books or houses that are a bit
obsolete and in some way they
motivate young people because every day more
with mobile tablets, well, make
classes a  a little more dynamic, not
even existing brings one more respect and it is not
really if this teacher
can
well you understand me if if not if it is from
this teacher who wants to send an
email to support atlanta com we can
send this platform no how to use
the lincoln class level there  because there are
certain conditions not to control
the students to control the contents that
are used
and others but it seems to me  I
have never been a teacher in a class
but it seems to me that if the
students want to listen and
read
then allow the language to
enter their head through this
listening and reading the classes would be for
explanations if the student has
questions  because I have heard a lot but
I do not understand why this is the case someone has found
out something that seems a
little strange to me can you explain if you are a teacher
and if the student is interested
in something then they will learn better but
if the teacher today we are going to do  I
don't know how to move, it's very difficult for it to
enter the
students' heads, but finally the best thing is
if this teacher starts to use the
link,
think of better ways to use
the link in the classes because I
'm not a teacher, but  It would be more
interesting for me to talk about the language to talk about
the stories that I have read
and it is not that the process the teacher
decides today we are going to do the conjunctive
we are going to do I don't know  other things
determined determined by the
curriculum no but I know that this is it
I am not a teacher because they tell you about
the benefits that the platform has
for schools that apart from accessing the
entire library of the link is enormous and I
'm fine it has  A section as a school
that can upload their content
privately, that is to say, they can create their
own lessons, their own courses
based on their methodology,
exactly opens a world because apart
from having the content they
can also have private
content.  You can also have a
private forum for your students to
communicate with your students, that is, it
also opens up a very large world for
schools to go a bit into the
digital world, not so much of books but something more
digital, and those that are open to this
world, I think  who is on the platform, he
hides all this a lot from him,
I'm going to say goodbye to you because I have an
Arabic class, it's worth starting, it's been a
pleasure to be here.
contact you
bye see you